hello and welcome to Android design in
action I'm your host Roman Nurik hey
guys my name's Adam Kosh and hi I'm Nick
butcher and today in our special episode
of Android design in action I feel like
I say special episode every week but
because it is a special episode yeah I
guess but this week it's actually a
special a very special episode we're
gonna be talking about what's new in
Android 4.4 KitKat which was just
recently announced we're going to talk
through a couple of specific changes a
couple of new design guidelines updates
that all designers should be aware of
when planning for Android 4.4 KitKat so
without further ado let's jump into the
content okay so the very first thing
that we should probably talk about is
the new Nexus 5 as with every platform
release for Android there's usually a
lead device as we call it I guess that
comes out and it's kind of the the
showcase device for that platform
release I think for Android 4.2 it was
the lows of the Nexus 4 the Nexus 10 I
forget already
and then for Android 4.3 is a new the
Nexus 7 2013 edition but anyway so for
Android 4.4
it's the Nexus 5 and the Nexus 5 as you
might imagine is about a 5-inch device I
think it's something like 4.95 inches
diagonally but here are some of the
interesting characteristics that you
don't really get from the spec sheet if
you will these are characteristics that
are very important for designers so the
first is that as seen at five inches so
it's a phone it's obviously very
obviously a phone not really a tablet at
all but next I think is is a very
important point here is the the screen
resolution in density-independent pixels
so as most of you know anytime you're
designing layouts or things like that
you should really be thinking in terms
of density-independent pixels rather
than just regular pixel units because
that more accurately represents the size
of the device which is very important
obviously for layout purposes so the
screen size of the Nexus 5 is 640 by 360
dips and that's actually the same exact
screen size in dips as the Galaxy Nexus
it's a little more narrow than the Nexus
4 but that's kind of the screen size
there and then the last bit of
information here is the logical density
of the device now the the screen itself
is about 440 points per inch or dots per
inch but the logical density as you guys
probably know you know we actually use
density buckets the logical density of
the device is xxhdpi or 480 dpi so if
you're creating assets now if you're
creating assets for you know for your
apps
you should definitely start thinking
about and actually if you haven't
already been thinking about it because
of other devices like the galaxy s4 or
the HTC One
you should definitely start thinking
about xxhdpi as kind of the highest
density assets so before we move on
anything else you guys want to say about
the Nexus 5 no really
it's a it's a great device yeah I'm just
discreet incredibly quick yeah it's it's
pretty amazing reading text on the
screen is just is a really really great
experience it's a it's beautiful here's
the Nexus we have a couple of Nexus 5's
but here it is I'm sure you guys will
see it in stores and all that whatever
anyway let's move on to branding Nick do
you want to talk about brainy yeah
absolutely so one of the changes in
KitKat is we've really tried to move the
system UI into a more kind of neutral
time so what I mean by that is in Prior
releases of Android we often used a very
kind of strong blue accent color which
you might have seen in the status bar
whether your notification icons go as
the signal strength and battery and so
forth as well as the default and kind of
crest state color whenever you touch on
any item or you know radio button
checkboxes and so forth and they would
have this very kind of like high
contrast blue and so the problem with
that was that it could very well clash
with their branding and the coloring
which you were trying to bring and to
your apps personality and
in Android 4.4 we've really toned back
this and this kind of and color palette
that OS uses in order to let the
applications stand out and show their
own personalities so the OS really does
kind of get out the way and doesn't kind
of impose its own personality within
your application and so you'll see this
throughout the application and in the
kind of the notification icon scheme
changing to kind of this Club muted gray
and white color as well as the change in
the default touch highlight States and
so yeah and as before like the idea of
this is really to allow you to bring
your own personality the app so as we've
called out here on the slide there's and
some tools out there such as Android
color closed upon which will help you to
kind of marry the holo visual theme the
look and feel of the buttons and
checkboxes and so it sports with your
own Brand X and colors
I'm having trouble zooming for some
reason but one of the things that we
should probably mention is that there's
a new section in the design guide called
the your branding section I think it's
under stifle design slash style and it
calls out specifically things that you
should keep in mind for example you know
using your brand accent colors rather
than using the default kind of hollow
blue everywhere you know use your brand
accent colors one thing I guess there's
important to note here is that you know
this has been around for a while the
guidance has always been to you know try
to customize to try to kind of find the
right balance visually between your
brand and holo and color is one of the
best ways to introduce your brand so now
we're kind of just formalizing that in
the design guide in this your branding
section so there's two examples here I
think in the guide the first is Google
Wallet using the the Google blue red
yellow and green colors throughout the
UI to add some flourishes as well as the
Google Play Music example which is a
very good example of branding where you
see orange basically everywhere
replacing stock blue so as part of this
new your branding section at the very
bottom you'll also notice the section on
icons
and specifically you know it talks about
the distinction between I guess visual
styling and iconography like I guess the
the actual glyphs are the meanings of
the icons so basically that's just to
summarize this point here at the bottom
it basically says you know when you're
coming from other platforms or when you
have an existing I guess visual style
for your icons make sure that if there's
something in the Android icon palette
that is you know is universal for
example sharing or refresh or things
like that make sure that you apply your
visual style to androids iconography so
you know use the the object or the
actual icon from androids palette but
apply your visual styling so here's an
example so let's say let's say you have
these three icons and you have you know
upload view on web and share so I os7
recently introduced kind of this new
visual styling for that platform where
they basically have kind of outlines as
the is the primary motif right
throughout each icon everything is
basically just an outline so here are
some of the icons you may build for say
on iOS 7 and they have a new share icon
it's um it looks like this but when
you're taking this to Android make sure
that you don't just blindly copy those
same icons the apply is whatever visual
styling you you seem or you deem
necessary for your app or you deem fit
for your app let's say in this case
again outlines but still use androids
actual icons so here is the Android
share icon is just an example of the
Android share icon with the outline
motif applied so this this section of
the your branding design guide pattern
or Style section really just kind of
formalizes that just make sure that you
are applying this you're not just
blindly copying the exact PNG assets
across across platforms and if you're
styling if you're visual style is you
know not outlines if it's something else
if it involves you know 3d effects or
whatever if if that's your you know if
that's your thing then that's fine as
long as you kind of maintain Andrew
iconography alright so let's let's move
on actually real quick just to you know
make that drive the point home so you
wouldn't use something like the top
right here on Android for sharing you'd
use something like the bottom right here
okay moving on touch feedback yes so in
android 4.4 kitkat I think as Nick
mentioned before touch feedback has more
of a neutral color applied to it so when
you look at these sort of system UI
widgets you'll notice now that there's
sort of this much more neutral color as
opposed to this sort of hollow blue that
you've become used to so in this
particular case we see a button the
standard Android widget for a button and
there's a 10% opaque black overlay
applied accordingly and when it comes to
implementing your own touch feedback you
should sort of follow a similar kind of
guideline so you should sort of have a
more subtle and neutral color tone and
of course if you're adapting for your
own brand and you have a color that sort
of matches your brand you could also
apply that when when creating it a touch
feedback we talked about touch feedback
on images the other week and the same
kind of applies there you can also go
with this sort of more neutral sort of
ten percent opaque black overlay or you
can apply your brand colors accordingly
yeah so basically anytime you have to
actually back in your app try to avoid
the stock default blue and actually the
the default blue if your developers out
there if you just use selectable item
background that is no longer blue it's
actually kind of like a light gray at
about ten or twenty percent opacity but
the idea is that it should be more
subtle and anytime you have touched
feedback or basically any widget in your
app make sure that it's not using you
know the stock blue unless blue is your
is your brand accent color make sure
that it's either something very neutral
like a grayscale tone or something like
that or your brand accents I think it's
the main thing okay moving on to
fullscreen so this is actually a new a
guideline it's under developer Tanager
that com such design and slash patterns
and this guideline talks about when and
how you should present fullscreen
you eyes to your users so there's two
modes - I guess approaches that they
talk about and the they're called lean
back and immersive so lean back you guys
have already seen before if you open up
YouTube and you start you know playing a
video the system UI the navigation bar
the thing was back home in recents and
the status bar the thing with your
status icons and your clock and all that
those kind of fade away and the
fullscreen is left for the video it's a
truly immersive video playback UI now as
soon as you touch the screen the the
navigation bar the thing with back home
recents and the status bar fade in now
it's this is called lean back because
generally if you're watching a video
you're not really interacting with the
screen right you're not like doing stuff
in the middle of the screen you're just
sitting back and watching the video and
so as soon as you touch the screen you
know the thing the bars appear that
basically you know prevents the app from
doing anything else on the screen now or
I guess using the or interacting yes
exactly
with immersive mode this is something
that's new in android 4.4 kitkat an
immersive mode basically again hides the
bars but it also allows the user to
interact with the middle of the screen
and immersive mode is more suitable for
things like games where you actually
need to interact with the screen or book
readers where you're kind of flipping
between pages now the the reason that
the Leanback mode as soon as you touch
the screen you know it shows the bars
the reason for that is really because
you know those those bars are critical
you know not having access or losing
access to back home or recent it can
fundamentally break your experience or
your usage of the device and so that's
why I kind of consumes that first touch
and shows them automatically in
immersive mode the way in which a user
can show the bars is by swiping down
from the top of the screen or swiping up
from the bottom of the screen and every
time actually I guess we'll we'll look
at this in a second
anytime you hide the bars in immersive
mode you basically see this actually no
not anytime the first time in a single
in a specific app the
hide the bars they'll see this pop-up
overlay type thing and you'll basically
say swipe up or swipe down from the top
of the screen to show access to to your
back home in recent and stuff like that
so as soon as you swipe down you'll
you'll actually you know see your your
bars again but the idea is that you know
now in this immersive mode you have you
can you know use touch events and
everything all in the middle of the
screen without you know showing the back
home in recents and it's really really
ideal for things like book readers and
games and things like that so we have a
full we're not talking into much more
detail on this it didn't it yeah yeah I
guess we could demo it so yeah we could
swipe that's not actually gonna work
because I think we're we're in a special
mode in our Nexus 10 but the the point
here is that we have so that this is a
new mode it's called immersive mode
we're gonna have a deaf byte released on
this very shortly and the dev byte is
basically gonna explain how you actually
use these api's it's actually very very
simple it's not a very complicated API
to use but it's very very powerful so
long story short if you're building a
game or a book reader or magazine reader
or anything like that make sure to check
out immersive mode in KitKat and you
have full control of exiting immersive
mode as well while the system provides
those gestures this swipe up from the
bottom or down from the top and be you
can also control that say for example
play books take say that every single
pixel so when you're you're reading you
get this fully immersive mode but if you
tap in gesture which they always use to
show the system Chrome so the action bar
comes back and they're kind of like text
controls come back but they also listen
for that's happen and restore the kind
of system UI as well so you have full
control over this exactly
alright let's move on transition bars
that Nick Nick talk about doesn't work
sure yeah so a slight variation upon
this this theme is translucent bar so
this is still showing the system
Chrome's as showing the status bar and
an navigation bar at the bottom and but
allowing your application to draw to
that same real estate with minimal
background protection applied and over
the top so this is used to great effect
by the new the new home screen the new
launch
application on the Nexus 5 which allows
and allows you to show the wallpaper
like from edge to edge of the screen
while still preserving those system
functions and your application can do
the same thing so if we go on to the
next slide take a look at a sample
application of the kind of thing you
could build so here's an application
which is using maps kind of as the main
UI element and here you can see that
we're extending the content all the way
behind the system bars so he really
gives you this immersive feel but the
map is the entirety of the canvas you're
going to and you just have this kind of
minimal background protection applied
and you can control what is drawn behind
the system bars so two points one from
there there's a slightly go ahead he's
gonna say as a slight not new in Android
4.4 but in a very recent update to the
Google Play services library and you now
have the ability to do more with maps
have a little bit more control over the
kind of stock UI maps Graham so that's
things like here we can see the locate
me and the zoom in and out button as
well as the kind of orientation and
Compass Point we can you can now set
padding on those controls so that if you
do have system UI such as this the
action bar at the top and system bar and
buttons at the bottom or even your own
controls overlaying the map you can now
cut them in so they will remain visible
and despite your ever chrome on top of
the map canvas yeah so I guess my two
points
turn into one point I want to make
because that was one of the points I
want to make one of the points I wanted
to make was the background there will
always be like II said there's always
some background protection I think in
this in this first iteration I guess
there will be a gradient so regardless
of what's shown
I guess regardless of what your app UI
is there will always be a gradient a
subtle kind of black to transparent
gradient behind both the status bar and
the navigation bar so just keep that in
mind when you're if you're designing
kind of screens like this okay and also
one thing I want to another thing I want
to mention is we don't really have
guidance on exactly how you should use
this yet so this is still kind of I'd
say in an exploratory phase one of the
thing
that I know that one of the engineers
mentioned was that you should try to
avoid using action bars in this case I
think that this is this translucent bars
type of UI is really designed for more
for like wallpapers or or kind of
wallpaper type apps apps that really go
full bleed with the content so it's not
really quite clear exactly how how you
should use this yet with other UI chrome
but W this is just one of our early
explorations all right let's move on to
launch right guys
all right so for Launcher icons
hopefully already aware they're normally
shown at 48 dips square of 48 dips now
on Nexus 5
due to the new launcher they're actually
showing larger actually about 25% larger
60 dips and then because Nexus 5 is an
xxhdpi device essentially in order for
the icons to show it that Crispus you
really need to include an X X X HT VI or
640 dpi icon yes we really just said
that so so the actual pixel their pixel
size of that icon is is 192 pixels and
this is somewhat similar to how tablets
behave previously with their launcher
they would actually show the icons
slightly larger and so it needed to sort
of dip into the the density bucket
that's one larger than the density of
the actual device and so I guess our
guidance here is you know - the icon is
just so important it's such an important
part of your application you should
really be including an asset that makes
it look its best on all devices and all
screen sizes and so that means in this
case you need to provide xxx HTTP eye
icon for the launcher icon and so right
now this applies to Nexus 5 since Nexus
5 has the this new kind of launcher
buuuut imagine that other devices in the
future would potentially do something
like this so basically you know just
kind of get ahead of the game start
including the these 640 dpi icons and
also I mean just just to kind of I guess
talk about how how this works with you
know tablets right if there was an X X
HD
be i tablet then you'd have to do this
anyway it just happens to be that you
know there's an xxhdpi phone that's now
using this this tablet scaling behavior
for Launcher icons okay let's let's move
on to new gestures so these aren't
exactly I guess new gestures but we're
kind of formalizing two new gestures in
our design guidelines so if you've got a
developer that answered that comm slash
design I think it's on their patterns
gestures I forgot but you'll see two new
gestures the first is an expansion of
double touch and the second is I guess
double touch to drag so the expansion on
double touch basically says if you're
looking at a photo right I mean or
something that's that's just zoomable
double touch should zoom it in if you're
in something like Google Chrome I like
that right exactly if you're in
something like Google Chrome or
something else that has kind of bits and
pieces of information laid out and you
want to double touch on one of those
bits and pieces of information basically
what this is saying is that you should
zoom in to to that content so if you're
in chrome and you're you double touch on
a column of text on a web page it'll
actually zoom to fit that come you know
of text so this basically says if you
have any other types of or if you're
building an app that is similar in terms
of what continent presents and the
layout in which it presents that content
this is something you should do so this
may apply to things like magazines or
books or things event the second and
this is a little more universally
applicable I'd say is anytime you have
double touch you know double touch to
zoom if you double touch and then drag
up or down with that same finger so it's
kind of like you know touch touch drag
up and down that should basically also
be a zoom so rather than zooming in by
fixed amount say you know 50 or a 2x or
whatever it is double touch and drag up
and down it's kind of like a dynamic
zoom so I think if you drag I forgot if
it's dragged up it's it's zoom in or
zoom out but an example of this is
Google Maps so if you open up Google
Maps right now and this has been around
for for quite some time if you open up
Google Maps right now double touch drag
up and down
I think up will zoom in
it's in Chrome as well and it's a great
way because you can do it
similar to a kind of like a pinching
gesture but you can do it one-handed
so it's great yeah so yeah that's that's
actually how I discovered it i was i was
using maps with one hand and i was
double touching a lot and then i
accidentally stumbled upon and i was
like oh my god this is the best thing
ever but yeah if you're building
something like this then then i
definitely use this i will say that we
don't have sample code available just
yet but i'll probably do an update to
our gestures training class for this at
some point
no gesture detector NIST's what
libraries being updated with this
excellent even better there you go
you've written the code for you awesome
awesome so my change to the training
class will be like one line of code or
something that awesome okay let's move
on to screen recording so this is just a
you know not nothing to change the way
you have to design your applications but
we've made it a lot easier to capture
video from the device so I think in
previous shows we've moved talked about
having specialized hardware or certain
devices which let you record the screen
output in order to create really high
quality product videos and but a new
system feature in android 4.4 called
screen recording will let you do this
via a simple and command so there's no
on device your wife actually doing this
this is kind of like a developer feature
and for producing these videos ahead of
time rather than like a runtime user
feature as it were and so you simply
execute this command written on screen
and this will record a 15-second up to
15 seconds of video in kind of them in
full high-definition the full power
screen resolution and and then you can
just pull the UVA to be pool commands in
order to kind of get that video file off
of the device and onto your computer so
a really easy way to record kind of
product videos as a little pro tip if
you enable if you go into the settings
and then developer settings section and
enable show touches as we have on this
tablet here you get these kind of like
white circles and which goes really well
with it and doing a screen recording so
you can produce high-quality photo
videos without having fingers in the way
and so forth
I also think we of did it to three
minutes or is it still 15 seconds I
think at some point we
I made a change to make it three minutes
but it's either three minutes or 15
seconds what other thing we should I
guess one of the things we should we
should mention is that what we're doing
right here with our with our own setup
here we're not using screen record
against screen record is not meant for
live screencasting it's really for for
recording video and then you know
post-processing are things like that so
it's really good for like things like
your promotional video and Google Play
if you want to show a video of your app
in use this will make it tons tons
easier alright last but not least scenes
in transition yes those things in
transitions so the animation framework
in Android gets some fantastic new
additions in Android 4.4 and we're
calling them scenes and transitions so
there's sort of two parts of this the
first is a where you can essentially
define scenes within your UI this is
sort of two different UI States for a
particular screen and then you can have
the system actually calculate the
animation to get from the first scene to
the second scene so this is a it's a
really neat addition and the second part
to this is you can actually go and
modify a particular view group so this
is sort of talking on the developer side
a view group is a collection of views
within a particular screen and make
changes for those and have the system
animate those changes as well so it's
definitely something to look into you
know if you want to get more involved
inside the animation side of Android for
developers there's the Android
transition transit transaction
transition man transition manager that
you should go look at to get more
information about this and if you're
familiar with keynotes sort of magic
move animation which sort of lets you
morph sort of an object from one portion
of the screen into another it's sort of
very similar to that so I'm just to sort
of give you an idea of how it works or
how it looks yeah and I think that the
the big thing here for designers is if
you're talking to a developer and you're
like hey I want these animations these
transitions to happen and they're like
oh you know I just can't do that it's
going to take too long
you know for earlier versions of Android
you know it does require a bit of work
it's definitely still doable but if
you're running Android 4.4 or later I
don't think there's an excuse anymore to
not use this API the great thing about
this API is that it's so simple I mean
the easiest form of this is one line of
code is basically just kind of I think
it's begin delayed transition or
something like that and it basically
says any time you show or hide or or
resize or move things automatically you
know adjust their bounds or animate
their bounds or or fade them in and fade
them out it's it's really awesome so I
think that for designers make sure that
you kind of press your developers to to
use this new API if they have any sort
of concerns over the amount of time it
would take to implement certain
transitions and lastly for developers
look for a dev pipe from our animation
expert chet haase which we live very
shortly as well yep okay so that's it
for for what's new in Android 4.4 KitKat
from a design standpoint watch out for
for all those dev bytes that we talked
about for developers and we're looking
to create a whole bunch of design bytes
on these topics as well over the you
know coming weeks or months hopefully
weeks so yeah so well stay tuned for all
that anyway so I see you next week or
the week after or whatever
as always I'm Roman Nurik so yeah see
you later guys Adam Koch here bye from
Nate butch in